[Applaudissements]
mathieu qui sait quoi il se prend pour
qui cela alors je remets à cyril hanouna
le laurier de l'animateur qui a bien
fait nous prévenir que son prime
finirait à 23 heures tapantes
ah oui c'est clair et net partira à 23
heures précises dit si tu lis chaque
paroisse les images de moi la bande à
tous mais bon on sait qu'avec vous quand
c'est l'heure c'est l'heure dont vous
terminez évidemment l'émission a aucun
rapport c'est complet
[Applaudissements]
est ce que tu me stoneham le point
commun entre les 37 minutes de
débordements état chronique la séparait
les deux sont gratuites j'étais pas au
courant
alors je dis maxime gagné a déclaré sa
flamme à une jeune tunisienne cyrine
moins de moyens le maillot pour la
séduire vraiment l'état font il a
notamment chanté en tout cas essayez et
vous verrez le dénouement tragique sa
100ème fouet mais ça ça a capoté vise à
capter sa santé vous allez le voir tout
de suite il n'y a pas eu le feeling n'ya
pas eu mal ma croûte dans le mani
coaticookoise allah ya pas eu le le
croquant dans leur jacques hoarau n'y a
pas eu l'or mais c'est vrai quoi n'a pas
énorme et on n'a pas eu beaucoup tout
dans la citronnade voilà résumé alors je
remets donc avec symbian il lauriers du
mec qui a du mal à gérer les mots qui
sortent de sa bouche puisque même quand
il chante il dit n'importe quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on drague et maxime n'a pas seulement
chanter aussi utilisé c'est formidable
don d'orateur
on parle pas de mariage habitudes d'une
union et pourquoi pas le fait de le
faire voilà la bonne humeur
alors forcément après déclaration aussi
on savait regardez combien ce tir in et
tomba les jetais pathé et oui je peux
pas te dire non mais c'est toujours le
bienvenu en tunisie
[Applaudissements]
bon là
ma
ou pas
chorégraphie
voilà bon vous verrez comment ça s'est
terminé en tunisie mais ça s'est même
pas tenu la main l'autre m'écoutais je
n'ai pas envie de revenir à turin on y
reviendra pendant le prime de la tunisie
ça a été un mois ça a été encore
influent soir un fût soir ce soir c'est
jouer le soir ça n'existe pas mais ça
m'a plu c'est ça ma puce team aime ça
[Applaudissements]
alors après le chocolat guèye est
chroniquement cette fois été victime du
téléphone gates a way ans depuis qu'il
est chez nous benjamin castaldi a vu son
numéro des volets dans l'émission encore
plus de foi qui s'est marié à marie
tiens c'est vrai c'est incroyable
pourquoi une dizaine de fois je crois à
peu près voilà donc jeudi benjamin s'est
vengé en donnant le numéro de l'animal
en plein direct on est bien sur l'animal
a répliqué en balançant son tour les
numéros des chroniqueurs alors qu'ils
n'avaient rien demandé les peaux
regarder ses lauriers du crâne que la
holding
si vous balancer au numéro là je
prendrai numéro d'un innocent un
animateur du patelin porte qui arthur
n'importe où voisard arthur aux
alouettes arthur ça peut être
denis brogniart ça peut être n'importe
qui ça peut être mais il était gens que
j'aime bien parce que des deux voilà
j'aime beaucoup nico pas là je vous dis
ça sera je donnerai numéro d'un innocent
je le fais maintenant
non non non vous savez ce sera kg 900
marc olivier fogiel connard voilà votre
meilleur ami
voilà ça sorte toujours ça marche
regardez c'est le laurier du chroniqueur
benjamin castaldi qui a enfin l'occasion
de se venger de son patron
mais qui kiffent surtout de ferraillage
ses collègues je donnerai le numéro de
tout nom pour prendre sa décision mon
benji a reçu un conseil de doc gynéco et
surtout benji reçoit un conseil encore
plus avisés de mokhtar portée
germain décide donc de porter ses yeux
coup et dévoile le numéro de l'animal
cyril hanouna qui quand il est choqué
répète toujours la même chose et prend
l'accent antilles et c'est bizarre
[Musique]
c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est le morcellement et oui jean brad
raisons qui n'ont pas été lancés en
janvier votre énergie pour l'action
itier parce que ça me détend c'est chaud
dans la nuit dans brasse tous les gens
qui nous sur votre loyer quand même
l'incrédulité de coiffer que alors s'il
vous plaît c'est hanoune alain bocquet 7
mètres sur des mots que je comprends la
suite la kinder balancier pas qu'il
irait jusqu'au bout
d'accord avait très bien ça se voit ça
se voit alors on sait qu'on peut vannes
et maxime gagné sur le fait qu'il n'a
pas sorti de scoop médias depuis
septembre 2014
by jove n'est elle a pas de sortie de ce
couvent il n'a pas sorti ne descend pas
grand chose mais tout est à l'intérieur
à qui sortent tous courir un bébé très
bien évidemment excusez moi juste un
ring
halloween c'est aujourd'hui bon en
général maxime reste toujours scène sauf
que jeudi on a découvert ce qui pourrait
le rendre
remonté comme un coucou away balancer
son numéro à l'antenne n'est jamais bien
comme ça franchement je n'avais pas vu
comme ça depuis la séparation des worlds
apart en quatrième je remets un maxime
kahn il l'aurait du gars qui a la plus
belle tête de sommes depuis les belges à
la dernière coupe du monde
aïda ville je donnerai le numéro de
toute annonce de possibles c'est
démarrer par le voir après cette menace
maximini est déjà au bout du rouleau
mais lors de la révélation de son numéro
on a carrément perdu
premier numéro ce sera le numéro de
maxime gagné d'ailleurs tôt dans le
match
après maxime au bout du rouleau on a
découvert le maxsym guinea loubards qui
n'hésite pas à sortir de ses gonds c'est
débile
le nombre d'enfants
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est en se disant ce numéro de
personnes dans le répertoire monchy tu
déconnes j'avais toutes les pages web
les mêmes tons numéro deux dans la
vuelta pays les plus il a pu lui même un
nouveau numéro de puits lâche
enchantement et ça c'est long à mettre
en place annonce à des fins cinq minutes
pour cirer des mois pour les ans que la
maxime du tout de suite et là mais veut
pas de mal aux îles salomon maxime grèce
mais devrait en fait je ne peut plus
appeler il faut pu me donner son numéro
et où d'ailleurs je vous ai demandé
votre numéro ou faisait pas voulu mais
des numéros mais venez pas besoin de
m'appeler franchement je le vois pas
pourquoi vous m'appellerez mais c'est
vrai que ça pelleriaux cayzac voilà ne
me plaît pas je me bats alors pour
terminer avec 4 bons numéros y aller ni
turbine je crois quoi caroline turbine
nom d'oblicore bid a minima comme gynéco
[Rires]
jedoch l'a donc là oui voilà à 0
qu'il aille à kodock j'ai confiance en
lui et puis de toutes les façons je vous
dire je suis sûr qu'il ne retiendra pas
surtout bon ça que je vais donner allez
mon bon fini vous savez que lundi on
fait 2 beyond et chroniqueur en ce qui
concerne leur intervention dans
l'émission ah ouais on fait ça pour voir
un peu qu'ils participent vraiment qui
vient ici en touriste ou à raconter
toutes les prises de parole sur les
émissions de la semaine dernière qui a
le plus parlé qui elle moi parler c'est
l'heure du classement 2 n'oubliez pas de
prendre la parole bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans ce nouveau classement
n'oubliez pas de prendre la parole
celui qui est oublié de prendre la
parole la semaine dernière est aussi
celui qui est le meilleur salaire
benjamin castaldi prix légal
vingt-et-une invention seulement
benjamin est donc payer 190 euros la
prise de parole un brin d'agacement
c'est le seul docteur qui n'a pas fait
d'études
doc gynéco 23 interventions toit a
percuté les unes que les autres
du classement celui qui a pris la parole
40 fois la semaine dernière c'est le roi
de la bafouille jean michel maire est
toujours numéro 1 avec 64 à l'invention
celui qui oublie malheureusement jamais
de prendre la parole à dieu de leur nom
semelles rouges n a pas d'accord cette
semaine pour être deux fois d'affilée
castaldi par contre je vais vous donner
mon numéro mois vous allez l'appeler ce
soir on va parler tous les deux que je
n'avais pas et de vent d'oc lie avant
tout aux banques et non mais là il faut
se poser les bonnes questions féroé mais
je voulais pause non mais franchement
mais mais vous ne parlez pas du tout en
fait je parle à bon escient et attend
des avancées techniques pour se passer
de la qualité je n'ai pas en tête là
donc c'est pas fait pour ça c'est pas le
pot pour l'ambassade mm et 5000 board
and haas alors oui c'est vrai
[Applaudissements]